just tell me your top five plays that
you've made up until this point
all right i'm gonna start with that same
game where i got hurt we saw my earlier
when uh
thomas hit me in my knee before that i
got an interception on peyton manning
you know that was crazy i got tackled on
the on the three yard line by peggy
manning two though but still i don't
care i picked off the goat one of the
goats you know and that's cool for
d-linemen we don't get many times
getting hands on the ball so for me
yeah i love that that's huge uh two you
know uh i remember like you know i grew
up
a diehard broncos fan because i grew up
in denver and uh you know i remember uh
the broncos beating you know um uh you
know brett favre
you know in the super bowl and i
remember just watching brett favre as a
kid and and then being able to play
against him in the nfl it was crazy now
he's playing for the vikings in 09 but i
i had uh i told coach i said coach man
there's this play like we we put in
earlier in that week and i was like yo
this if you call this place got work and
he was okay i'm gonna call the next
third down he called it and so my mom
was like i gotta make it work and i beat
my guy ripped inside grabbed brett favre
and like suplex so that's back where you
can kill quarterbacks i did get fired
though
he said i did get fun
well i said brett favre you could you
know you know he's a legend guy grew up
watching so that's cool
um
when i went back to arizona
and um my first time you know i thought
i was gonna be i was on the cardinal for
life and i ended up going to
jacksonville and you know ended up being
a blessing in disguise because i had you
know probably my best my best season
ever in jacksonville but we went back
that year uh you know my man uh yanica
gakway forced the fumble and i scooped
it and went and i scored man and uh
scored a touchdown
and uh in that stadium and i wasn't sure
if they was gonna boo me like you know
like seeing seattle
russell wilson i thought that was crazy
uh but nah the arizona cardinals at me
they didn't boo man they showed me some
love i heard a whole lot of sharing in
there when i scored a touchdown now they
won the game so i think it was easier
for them uh for them for them to cheer
but uh it was cool to have the stadium
still showing me so much love going back
um you know uh yeah then you know i we
had a a game back in i don't know what
year it was but uh you know every time
you play against tom brady man it's
always a great game right again where i
stacked him twice you know but there was
uh you know that first one yeah right
there get him so second time brady that
was that was huge
and then um
dang
i mean there's so many great plays but
uh you know i'm gonna go back to the
like my first like big play
and i don't remember if it was christmas
or thanksgiving it was one of them like
holiday games playing against the
cowboys and i was a rookie
and um and there was uh marion barber
had kind of like a little little screen
pass and he cut back and he see me
coming
and i came through and i hit him with
everything i had he cut and he fumbled
you know coughed up the ball
and uh we ended up scoring and we ended
up winning that game and that was one of
the crucial players to win in the game
is just like you know that was like when
i realized like i could be a star in
this league